well what i'm going to have a go at is
to solve this problem
and let's bring this actually i will
bring it back to the middle so i have
some space now on the left and right
i'm going to solve this problem and make
it a lot easier to work with but
to begin with it's going to look harder
you've got to stay with it all right
for starters what i'm going to do
mysteriously you'll see why in a second
is i'm going to take logs
of both sides and i'm going to use the
natural log because it's the easiest
to differentiate so i'm going to get
natural log
of f of x over here
and that leaves me with the natural log
of x to the power of x
over there okay now i know this looks
like it's unnecessarily complicating
things why would i do this what's the
point
well the answer is if you have a look
over here on the right hand side
there's some logos here that can help
you have a think about why this
problem as a whole is difficult to solve
the answer is because you've got an
x in the base over here and you also
have an x in the power
and the fact that you have both of those
at the same time that's what makes this
weird and complicated
but because i've now written things as
log
x to the power of x i can actually
eliminate
that problem i can use one of my log
laws have a think about this i wonder if
the
you know ideas are connecting in your
head what law
can i use with logarithms that allows me
to get rid of that
x that's up in the index there well
i can actually use the fact that i can
bring down this index
out the front this is one of our log
laws so i can write the
right hand side as x times log
x now this is still not particularly
neat
it's still a bit messy but at least i
can work with it and this is something i
do know how to differentiate
it's going to be using the product rule
and i can handle that
over there on the left hand side i still
have log of
f of x there's not much i can do with
that at the moment we'll come to that
shortly
now remember i'm trying to understand
this turning point right like
what the dickens is going on here let's
get rid of that because it's not the
derivative
i'm trying to understand what's
happening here and why it turns around
why there's this minimum going on here
so in order to do that i need the real
derivative
so therefore i'm going to differentiate
both sides of this now i know this
sounds weird
i'm trying to differentiate both sides
of an equation but differentiation is an
operation
much like you know adding or subtracting
or
squaring it's not exactly the same but
because i've got an equation here and
both sides are apparently the same thing
i should be able to differentiate both
sides and i'll get something that makes
sense
so let's give this a go i'm going to use
the differential operator d on dx
and then i'm going to get let's see here
i'm going to do this a little bit
quicker
log of f of x on the right hand side
and then i'm going to also be
differentiating on the right hand side
and i've got x log x there
all right now i can take this one step
at a time let's have a look at the left
hand side first
this is going to be the chain rule isn't
it because i've got a function
of a function log of
f of x now i actually know what f of x
is it's a
it's x to the power of x up there but
for now i'm just going to
state the chain rule like the rule for
it
i'm just going to state it without
worrying about what the particular f of
x
is so when i take the derivative
of log f of x we deal with the inside
and the outside
well the inside is f of x so its
derivative
i would normally write as f dash x
that's the inside derivative then i have
a look and i say i'm going to multiply
by the derivative of the
outside function the outside function is
log of something
natural log i should say and the
derivative of that is 1 over
whatever's inside the brackets 1 over f
of
x in this case all right so that's it
i've differentiated the left hand side
now i want to have a look at the right
hand side if you look carefully here
i've got a product like i said before
let's call this u
and call this v i'm going to write my
derivative as
v u dash plus u
v dash so let's do it one step at a time
v i'm writing as log x
u dash well u is just equal to x so u
dash will just equal to
one there's v u dash i'm now going to
add
and we do it the other way around so u
is just going to be
x and then v dash this is log
x so as we saw before this is 1 over
x ok so
this is good i've differentiated the
left hand side i've differentiated the
right hand side
this is actually the hardest part even
though i know what i've got
in front of me looks like a garbled mess
i can deal with this
it just requires me to do a bit of
rearranging now before i do the
rearrangement what i want you to
remember is
why did we do all of this why do we
introduce logs on both sides why don't i
introduce this differential operator
well the whole point was i wanted to
take this
f of x and i wanted to work out what its
derivative was
its derivative f of x by definition is f
dash x and what's interesting is i
already have
f dash x over here it's sort of popped
up
by doing this chain rule over here on
the left hand side so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to leave that f dash
x over there on the left hand side i'm
going to make that the subject
by multiplying through by this other
object that i have here
the 1 over f x i'm going to multiply by
f of x
and that will cancel that fraction so
what are we getting here
i've got f dash x on the left hand side
i'm going to multiply the right hand
side and both sides in fact
by f of x and then i'm going to simplify
what i have remaining so i've got this
log
x times 1 that's just log x and then
i've got
x times 1 over x well that's just 1.
there we go now i'm almost there
this point here i've got my derivative i
just need to tidy it up
f of x by definition what we started
with the first line
is x to the power of x and then what's
in the brackets here is log
x plus one interestingly this is very
very close
to what we had before just that plus one
seems to be different
okay now why do i have this well now
that i know what the derivative is
f dash x equals this gobbled mess i want
to know
where does it turn around right well i
can actually say
stationary points exist when this
derivative here
is equal to zero those will give me
stationary points
and with any luck stationary points will
give me turning points we know we can
have
horizontal points of inflection which is
a stationary point that doesn't turn
around it just sort of pauses and then
it just keeps going in the direction
that was going before
but i know because i've seen the graph
that the stationary point i expect to
find
should also be a turning point so let's
have a go at solving this i'm going to
write this down
stationary points exist when
my derivative equals zero f dash
x equals zero so what that means is
in other words when does this thing
equal
zero now you may look at this and think
i don't even know where to start
solving a problem like this well take it
one step at a time
what you've got here is on the left hand
side a product it's a weird looking
product but it's a product nonetheless
there's this object over here that's a
bit too
thick let's try and make that a little
easier to see you've got this object
over here
x to the power of x and then it's
multiplied by let's choose another color
like
like this guy like this log
x plus 1 is the other part of the
product x to the power of x
and log x plus 1. now when i multiply
through
to get 0 what that tells me is at least
one of these two pieces
has to equal zero right if you've got
two numbers if i just called them hey
i've got two numbers a and b and if i
said to you when you multiply them
together
you get zero then one of the numbers at
least
has to be zero if both numbers are not
zero no matter what numbers you combine
their product won't be zero so that
means either this blue guy or this green
guy one of them has to be zero
now if i go back to my graph graphs are
always so instructive and helpful
this is x to the power of x this is the
left left-hand part of the product
now as i zoom out you can see this
function
never actually touches the x-axis it
never comes down
to zero so x to the power of x
never equals zero in any part
of its domain so if the blue part of the
product
can't equal 0 then it has to be this
green part of the product
that's the part that's going to equal 0
at some point
so therefore i can say what i'm really
solving is when is that
part log x plus 1 when does that equal 0
this i can solve i can say log x
and i'm going to subtract 1 from both
sides equals
negative one now some of you you'll look
at that and your brain will fizzle out
because you'll be like wait hold on a
second
you can't take logs of negative numbers
why have i got a negative number there
well remember i'm actually not taking
the log of a negative number
i'm taking the log of some number over
here and its result
is a negative number to help you
understand this let's rewrite
log natural in its longer form which is
log base e
of x equals negative 1. in order to
solve this guy
i want to rearrange this logarithmic
equation into an
exponential equation so i'm going to
take this
e which is in the base over here it's
going to become the new base
of my new exponential equation and then
my other numbers are going to rearrange
the negative 1 is actually the power
and the x will become the subject it's
written on the right hand side i should
write it over there on the left instead
e to the power of negative 1 think back
to your index laws
a negative index actually indicates
division right so this is really 1
over e now e is about
2.7 2.718.
so this number here it's close to a
third one over three
and we can test this out let's actually
go back to our graph
i'm going to go ahead and evaluate 1
divided by
e like i said it's pretty close to a
third 0.367
and i can test to see whether this is
the right spot
by actually graphing let's go back over
here
this is my x value and you can see
it lines up exactly with where i saw my
stationary point and in fact
i think you can actually cheat a little
bit if you click on a graph in desmos
it'll tell you exactly where the
stationary point is
and there it is there's the 0.36
it's rounded off point there which lines
up exactly with the turning point we
located
so in summary this turning point mystery
right like why does this function have
a turning point at all when the things
that we came from
this this polynomial and this
exponential they didn't have
turning points in the domain we were
interested in well this is one of those
counter-intuitive results
that comes from well is revealed by
calculus
this shows us why it's happening when
you have a look at the derivative
you can see there must be a stationary
point it must
turn and you can see on either side of
this one over e
stationary point you can go ahead and
you can test that you'll have a
decreasing gradient for one part and
increasing for the other i should say
increasing
so we can also locate its position as
we've just seen
by solving for when the derivative
equals to zero so to anyone out there
wondering about this weird function
and how we can understand it i know it
looks like you can't actually
differentiate it to begin with but using
all the tools we knew
log rules product rule chain rule and
not giving up persevering to try and
untangle this you actually can see this
result hope it makes sense
and that it's an interesting result for
you